[Music]
[Music]
tonight's speaker dr. Tudor when when we
first met to discuss the potential of
her speaking here it became really clear
that that she embodies an aspect of long
now which we talk about here sometimes
it's it's the big here it's the it's the
corollary with the long now if you know
the story it stems from and you should
look up Brian Eno's essay of the big
hair and the long now a realization that
when we are too focused on where we are
are very near locales and not thinking
about a larger world we are limiting the
potential the understanding and and then
the possibility that we can have you
know in our lives and and and as this
greater human cooperative effort around
the planet so Brian said Brian Eno's
said I want to live in a bigger here and
a longer now what you'll find tonight is
that Maya tutors work and actually her
life are something that inherently
spanned the geographies and and offer
her a perspective which she's digging
into and learning more about to share
with us tonight truly kind of a global
truly a big here kind of perspective so
without any further ado please give a
big round of applause for tonight's
speaker Maya Tudor
all right good evening and thank you to
the long now for inviting me and to
Margaret for being my discussant I'm
really delighted to be here and to have
an opportunity to talk about my new book
project so unlike some of my colleagues
that causes some of whom are here
tonight and thank you for being here I'm
really at the beginning of this exciting
new project so the topic of my talk
tonight is whether nationalism can be a
resource for democracy but before I tell
you about my research I want to do a
little bit of research right here right
now so I'd like you all to just close
your eyes for a moment and to raise your
hands if you consider yourself to be a
nationalist all right keeping your eyes
closed please raise your hand if you
would consider yourself committed to
democratic institutions all right thank
you so as I suspected we had three hands
raised to describe themselves as the
Nationalists so most of you do not think
of yourselves as nationalists and the
vast vast majority of you think of
yourselves as Democrats Democrats with a
small D committed to democratic
institutions and that I suspect that
part of the reason you don't think of
yourself as a nationalist or most if you
don't think of yourself as a nationalist
is because you think that you have a
particular vision of nationalism what
that means in your mind and that you
think of that at least in some respects
at the name a call to democracy and over
the next half an hour I hope to convince
you that at least in part you're wrong
about some of those associations so
Michael alluded to my personal story so
I thought I'd start by by telling you a
little bit about myself so I got
interested in questions of nationalism
in part because I'm sort of remarkably
confused about my own national identity
you might think of me as America and I
sound American but I was actually born
in India too
Indian father with an Indian passport
but I spoke my mother tongue was German
so I spoke German with my German mother
who lived at the time in India so it was
born with two citizenships and if that
wasn't confusing enough when my parents
my parents marriage broke up my mother
remarried an American who adopted me
thereby giving me American citizenship
you can see the pattern here with the
flags that you see a then went to
American schools but mostly not in the
United States but abroad and in most of
my schooling in the United States but
about a decade ago actually exactly a
decade ago I moved to the United Kingdom
where I've lived the past decade giving
me the right to yet another nationality
but if like me you've been in England
last summer you wouldn't have seen the
Union Jack flag flying you would have in
fact seen the English flag flying
because the World Cup was being played
last time I so I'm kind of I'm my
personal story in many ways epitomizes
the the sense that I have from my
research that national identities are in
some sense fictive but as I hope to
return to at the end I think that can
actually be quite a hopeful story but if
I am a kind of multiplicity a hodgepodge
of national identities I'm gonna tell
you about the story the personal story
of my family
and that's actually a particularly a
story of my two grandfather's and they
don't have a hodgepodge of national
identities they were very much rooted in
one place and at one time so this is a
picture here of my German grandfather
here he is here on his wedding day to my
my grandmother and he was somebody who
was completely uninterested in politics
he wanted to be a linguist but as was
the case as he was the eldest of five
children he didn't really have a choice
in the matter in vimar Germany he needed
to take a job to support his family help
support his his five siblings which he
did and though he was very uninterested
in politics and didn't join a political
party
and didn't really want his life to be
defined by nationalism it was defined by
nationalism as many of you all know
Germany of the 1940s was very much
defined by nationalism and it's that
kind of nationalism led by leaders like
this that you probably have in your
minds when you think about this term
nationalism so when most people think
they think of again as leaders like this
and the mass mobilizations that they led
which led to the destruction of
democracy and in many of the countries
in Europe at the time and it was this
historical legacy which led many of the
greatest leaders of the twentieth
century or thinkers the 20th century to
reject nationalism as a force to be
embraced so here you have from left to
right reppin the Nath Tagore Virginia
Woolf and Albert Einstein all Nobel
Prize winners maybe we should have
Margaret up there as well rejecting the
forces of nationalism it they really
thought nationalism was something to be
rejected and they very much and their
other writings hoped that nationalism
would fall away in the future that they
envisioned but if this story of one of
my grandfather's tells you about the
ways in which nationalism can undermine
or destroy democracy the story of my
other grandfather tells you a very
different kind of story about the
relationship between nationalism and
democracy and this is a picture of my
Indian grandfather you can see him here
he also like my German grandfather was
completely uninterested in politics
didn't join a political party and yet
like my other grandfather his life was
in many ways up ended by the forces of
nationalism
he was he joined an Indian colonial
India's educational institutions was
educated there and through that
opportunity joined the Indian civil
service which was of course run ran
India under British colonial rule and
was accused by
some of his compatriots as actually
being a traitor because he served
essentially a colonial government and as
the forces of nationalism rose in his
country it was a kind of nationalism
that created democracy but one which he
held a kind of tenuous position and so
when independence came as it came 1947
for India he had to learn to serve
essentially a new master and you can see
a picture of him there in the centre
essentially taking instructions from
India's first prime minister Jawaharlal
Nehru so this story tells of a very
different kind of relationship between
nationals and them and democracy a kind
of nationalism here that was actually
used to create democracy not to
undermine it and in fact many of the
greatest political leaders of the 20th
century very much thought of themselves
as nationalists here you see a quote
from Gandhi who said it's impossible to
be in internationalist to be have
commitments beyond one's nation if one
is not first a nationalist and indeed
Nelson Mandela had a very similar
perspective on nationalism although I am
a nationalist I am by no means a
racialist so he very much thought of
himself as a nationalist but he
understood that there was the kind of
nationalism that was not defined by
racial identities so when we think today
about the forces of nationalism that are
sweeping the globe we think about these
kinds of faces we think about Trump the
pen or bong Xi Jinping and Narendra Modi
and these leaders in fact do espouse a
kind of nationalism that I and my
research is showing is bad for democracy
because the kind the conception of the
nation that they espouse is a conception
that's based on a particular a fixed
identity and what that does is it
creates for those individuals in the
nation
we all live in multi-ethnic
multi-religious nations now it creates
groups who don't have that core national
identity and who are therefore thought
of as out groups that can be easily
marginalized in times of crisis but if
we have these kinds of leaders today as
we do
there are also leaders it's important
not to forget who do espouse
nationalisms that are not based on
racial ethnic religious regional
identities but that are espouse the kind
of nationalism that is based on creeds
and principles so it's the Stute the
story the contrast between my two
grandfather's lives and the contrast
between these the kinds of leaders I've
just talked about that led me to my
current research project and that
project is animated by the question when
is nationalism a resource for creating
and protecting democracy and when
alternatively is it a resource for
undermining it so before I talk a little
bit more about this project I just want
to spend a few moments on what I mean by
these terms because there are almost as
many definitions of these terms as there
are people who study them and that's a
lot so what is a nation so three of the
most kind of celebrated thinkers of
nationalism across through the three
different fields of philosophy sociology
and political science have called a
nation an invented tradition an imagined
community and lies that bind so these
very pithy definitions all share in
common a conception of the nation as
something that is in a sense fictive
it's imagined and in some sense it's not
real and of course if you wind the clock
that long now clock back a couple
hundred years you wouldn't have seen
nations as the predominant form
political form across the globe at all
so it's of course in some sense it has
to be imagined because it hasn't always
been around but if that's the definition
of a nation it's some sort of community
but it's an imagined one then the ism of
a nation or
nationalism I call that this is really
my definition an identity binding
together individuals who share a large a
sense of large-scale political
solidarity often aimed at creating
legitimating or challenging States now I
want to draw your attention to a couple
parts of that definition so it isn't
first of all in that entity that binds
just because it's fictive or imagined
doesn't mean it isn't very real 4p in
people's minds at any particular moment
in time it is a form of solidarity so it
does create an amount economy community
that is imagined it is a community it
might not be community for whom you
never meet many of your Co nationals but
it is a community nonetheless the second
part of the definition that really
matters here is that it's large-scale
it's the largest scale at which we've
been able to imagine that I have that
kind of solid area for people we'll
never meet and in some cases share very
little in common with and the third part
of that definition that I want to draw
your attention to is that it's very much
associated with States
all right nation states are often put
together in the same hyphenated clause
for a reason because states are the kind
of it's you know the states and nations
associated with them are perhaps the
most universally legitimate political
creative are times and because
nationalism is a resource for States
it's it's something that we need to take
I think much more seriously and study
much more carefully so if that's what
nationalism is the other definition that
I just want to want to talk a bit about
is democracy
it can mean very different things to
different people so I'm using it in a
very political science not way in which
I centralize three components so I think
of democracy as a three-legged stool in
which each of the stools is is
represented by first elections second
competition that makes those elections
meaningful and third
broad range of civil and political
liberties for all citizens that includes
the right to free speech the right to
assemble together to articulate common
interests the right to protest and the
right to a media through as a medium for
for having those discussions now
classically political science has
explained democracy through a whole
range of structural explanations I'm not
going to talk about any of those
explanations and I'm very happy to take
questions on them when the Q&A comes but
notice that many of those explanations
really focus on on economics and on on
how web the size of the middle class and
how wealthy the country is on how much
inequality or equality there is in the
country what the economy is based on in
terms of exports and the like but
there's very little discussion of status
and equalities that the ideas that make
us unequal the focus is very much on
material factors and while you might not
know how much money your neighbor makes
you might not know even what their
social background is you do know that
the process of the national conversation
in politics whether your group a group
that you belong to is thought of as
second-class citizens and it's this
attempt to ground a serious study a
rigorous study of inequalities of
citizenship that I want to bring to the
to the political science conversations
that I have with my colleagues so the
core hypotheses that I'm developing in
my research are that an inclusive
national narrative one that's based on
Creed's ideas principles as some of
you've read so Yama's recent work on
identity he calls us creedal nationalism
that that all else being equal helps
actually to support democracy whereas an
exclusive national narrative one that's
based on a fixed identities of race
religion caste ethnicity religion being
in most parts of the world as an
identity undermines democracy all else
being equal before I kind of unpack
those hypotheses and what I'm doing to
research and and and and test these I
want to I wanted to spend a moment on
two questions I often get asked when I
present this research so the first
question is am I not really collapsing
the distinction between patriotism and
nationalism right so isn't patriotism
kind of all the good stuffs about
feeling love for one's country and
nationalism all the bad stuff well no
serious scholar that I know of
nationalism actually takes a distinction
very seriously it's a very big part of
the public debate but the very same
actions can look can be described as
patriotic or nationalist depending on
whether you like them or not and what
outcomes you think that they have but to
describe a phenomenon an analytically
it's important not to describe it based
on its consequences but would be able to
describe the font phenomenon in and of
itself and love for one's country
certainly can just be part of because so
patriotism can some researchers show and
quite easily slide into nationalism when
the circum went especially when
circumstances of threat arise the second
question I get asked a lot is wooden
isn't the ideal world one in which we
don't have national identities at all
right why I celebrate national
identities why why really promote them
in some sense if the ideal world is one
in which we all just are our primary
identities are ones that are based on
our common humanity and the answer I
give to that is that um there's a lot of
social psychology research that shows
that human beings are by their very
nature clannish and they need
communities and
that in fact the countries around the
world that we've seen that don't have a
national identity there come closest to
not having a national identity are not
utopian but in fact very dystopian and
what you see here is a picture of
Somalia where there is no clear not
national identity at all
so um I go about this research neither I
said I'm at the very beginning of this
project so this is a sort of a
relatively light on a lot of evidence
but I'm I'm going to tell you about how
I'm going about this research in in
three domains the first domain is that
I'm looking at sort of to look at like
for like I'm looking at all countries
that gained colonial independence in the
1940s and 50s and 60s and looking at
their founding constitutions and
creating an index of inclusivity based
on such questions as does the preamble
to the Constitution the part that begins
with We the People is there a definition
of the nation that mentions race
religion or region is there a religious
or racial category that's required for
to either be a head of state or to serve
an important distinction of government
and using these kinds of questions I
create an inclusive 'ti index that I'm
statistically looking at whether it has
that has a pattern with a whole bunch of
databases that look at democracy so I'm
in the process right now of putting that
together so that's the first way I do
that the second way that I do that I
investigate the relationship between
nationalism and democracy is that I'm
looking at some experiments which show
that when you look at you ask
individuals how much are you willing to
give to Co FNX or Co religious
co-religionists in need and that when
you actually prime individuals for
example by showing them a national flag
they're actually the different they're
there every one is more likely to give
to their Co as
in most contexts but when you prime them
individuals by showing the national flag
they actually are less likely to want to
give to that they're equally likely to
want to give to members of their nation
so very much shows that nationalism is a
force for solidarity and the Third Way
and that's the what I'm going to talk
about a little bit more tonight is that
I'm looking at countries that are
largely similar so three sets of
countries that are largely similar on
those explanations I gave you but that
have very different national identities
that their founding and I trace over
time whether and how those national
identities get used in moments of crisis
so what I'm going to talk to you about
tonight is about two of those countries
which are India and Myanmar and that's
what the map up there is Casey we're
wondering what that is so India and
Myanmar as I said were both part of
they're very similar on many of those
major Oh actually I think all of those
major explanations of democracy they
were very relatively poor hugely
ethnically diverse part of the same
British colonial regime until 1937 when
Myanmar were then Burma was cleaved off
to create a separate a separate
political entity and these two countries
have had very different trajectories in
terms of democracy and then I'm gonna
unpack that a little bit and talk about
both the founding national narratives
and how those narratives have been used
in moments of crisis so India's national
narrative was based it was a highly
inclusive founding nationalism that I
argue have three components that I think
are really that actually I've written
about in my previous book that were
important to the creation of its
democracy so the first is that it really
rejected caste hierarchies I don't know
how much many of you know very much
about India but prior to the nationalist
movement that was led by by Gandhi and
narrow among others caste completely
saturated
Indians a society who you ate with where
you walked where you drank your water
from who you married all of that was
determined by caste so this was highly
unequal in society and about the most
infertile social territory I can think
of for democracy but under the
nationalist movement led by Gandhi there
was a very clear rejection of caste
hierarchies within the national identity
so it's not that I rejected it entirely
but that within the nation caste was not
at all a central tenet of defining the
national identity here what you see is a
picture of Gandhi in front of the sabor
mati ashram and here he was really he
asked members of Congress many of whom
actually were high casted its founding
to come to this ashram to clean their
own toilets to eat together
those were things that had never been
done and on a wide on a large-scale
basis in Indian society before so it was
a national and that very much rejected
caste hierarchy second it was a secular
nationalism although it's a majority
Hindu country it did not use national
religion as the basis for creating the
national identity so what you see here
is the symbol of the Indian national or
the Indian national flag flag being the
kind of the most visible visible symbol
of the nation and initially these colors
orange white and green represented
respectively the Hindu majority the
Muslim minority and then a range of lot
of other minorities as you can see they
have equal place in in the in the symbol
of the nation and the the wheel you see
at the centre is actually a Buddhist
wheel so this is not it was not a
national identity that that centralized
religion in any strong way and finally
it centralized the right to
non-violently descent if you any of you
know anything about India's nationalist
movement you probably know about this
kind of the this part of it the
the Gandhi led civil disobedience
movement this by the way is not an
actual picture of a moment it's a
picture from the movie because no
pictures were taken at that moment but
this is this is where when Gandhi had
actually been jailed and the top
nationalist leaders have been jailed
Gandhi asked his followers to go and
collect salt from a mill which the
colonial regime had a monopoly on and
this was really as many of the mass
civil disobedience movements were was a
movement that that said that or that
centralized the right to protest an
unjust set of policies so India creates
its democracy it's a surprise in German
course I'm very happy to about talked
about that circumstances and again
that's the subject of the book I've
already written but what I'm interested
in now and looking at moments of crises
and in 1975 coincidentally the year I
was born in India India has a democracy
is really in crisis along all those
three dimensions I told you about
India's democracy sees the precipitous
fall so Indira Gandhi the daughter of
its first Prime Minister jails and
political opponents she muzzles the
press she postpones elections my mother
interestingly received who was a
outspoken critic of the Indira Gandhi
actually received a threatening letter
in which he said foreigners can also be
arrested in Indira Gandhi's India and so
this was a moment where actually in some
of the databases which look at democracy
this is actually among established
democracies the biggest single fall and
one year in that database so it's it's a
crisis but interestingly in January 1977
that crisis ends with a little bit of a
surprise because Indira Gandhi calls
elections and so this is a kind of
democratically elected leader
autocratically begun to overreach calls
elections and what happens so that's the
moment I'm really spending
time researching what happens in the
eight weeks between when political
opponents are released the political
political opposition comes together
under united front to try to unseat the
incumbent in their a Gandhi and I argue
I'm going to argue and this is my first
case study that the opposition movement
really weaponize as this inclusive
conception of the India's nation to
unseat in their a Gandhi's government so
these are relatively these are votes
that are quotes that are relatively
representative of what the kinds of
things that the opposition says which is
that the opposition movement is even
more important than the freedom movement
the nationalist movement because today
all our freedoms are gone and the only
difference is that we have our own ruler
where fundamental rights ever suspended
during British rule and another another
quote which centralizes you know the the
teachings of Gandhi and so what I did is
I looked at centrist newspapers in an
and the coded every word the opposition
said that was recorded in these
newspapers in those eight weeks and this
is the result of that and what you can
see Congress and junta are the names of
the political parties that were in
opposition so it's not surprising that
those were the most frequently uttered
words but when you leave the names of
the parties aside you notice that words
like India people country actually are
very common themes and what the
opposition is saying Gandhi actually
also here to see up there are actually
affair is refers not to Indira Gandhi
who was referred to as Indira but to
Gandhi the founding father so I really
am running that in this moment in
India's kind of greatest democratic
crisis to date nationalism is used as
actually a force to protect its
democracy and Myanmar by contrast has a
very different story Myanmar has
founding nationalism centralizes not
only the Buddhist religion
the boom our ethnicity here's a picture
of the Burmese King addressing some
monks
this is Burmese King before he was
deposed and the Anglo anglo-burmese war
of 1886 and what sort of so interesting
about this picture to me is that I don't
know how well you can see it but the
here's the king standing in front of a
collection of monks and it's not the
King that's sitting resplendent in a
throne like like Cersei and Game of
Thrones but it's actually the king is
standing there on a lower platform you
can see the monks are sitting on an
elevated platform it's the king that's
standing and the monks that are sitting
so who is really paying respects to whom
or who is is uppermost and in the
hierarchy is at least unclear here and I
would argue that it's very much the
Buddhist monks and that's because really
from time immemorial Buddhism the
Burmese kings right to rule has been on
the basis that he is the protector of
Buddhism and the Burmese nationalist
movement really did very little to
change that here in 1906 and a 1933 the
earliest rumblings of the Burmese
nationalist movement were really
movements that protected the religion
and argued that Burma was for the Burman
that is the Burmese ethnic identity and
there was a brief moment in 1947 when
the father of gong song su Chi general
long song tried to change this and match
with a number of the leaders of various
ethnic groups that are in the geographic
periphery of Burma so very much on the
rim there of what is modern-day Myanmar
but that was very that was a very brief
moment and it was quashed when he was
assassinated later that same year along
with a number of the other nationalist
leaders and Burma
then came received its independence in
1948 under a prime minister that very
much continued to centralize these
themes of Burma
for the Berman's and of the buddhist
national of buddhism essentially
defining the buddhist the burmese
national identity so in fact you did it
you see that things like the state
religion promotion act or central again
a part of how the Burmese regime
functioned even under this early period
of democracy that early period ends with
a military coup of 1962 which is
continues to be which puts Burma under
non democratic rule for over well over
20 years now in 1988 there is a mass
uprising against the military regime and
this leads to a concession to hold
elections and if any of you know much
about if any of you know anything about
Burma you probably know this story of
Ong song su Chi she was here in Burma at
the time home nursing her sick mother
and it's at that moment when she decides
to set up the National League for
Democracy this Protima cretak movement
and she contests elections in 1990 she
wins her party the National League for
Democracy wins about eighty-five percent
of the vote but a few months after those
elections are held the military comes
again quashes that tentative democratic
experiment so in in 2007 that's when you
see the real democratic opening and it's
not a surprise when you see a real
democratic opening coming after Buddhist
monks are actually the ones to protest
and you see in the 1988 it's actually
primarily students who are protesting so
when the kind of core signifier of the
nation turns there they're begging bowls
upside down that's when you see a real
democratic opening and the military
regime says we've got to start now
really conceding a roadmap for democracy
and in 2015 they hold elections we're
all sons and she earns and her National
League for Democracy earns virtually the
same percentage of votes I was actually
an observer in those elections for the
Carter Center
so these this is a moment where you get
after a long arc of military rule you
get a real democratic opening but the
key crisis I would say it's not one
that's in the past for Burma for Myanmar
but it's the crisis that we're seeing
today that begins in 2017 with a
military systematically expelling some
people with would would say some of the
human rights observers would say
committing genocide against there were
hinga Human Rights Watch currently calls
the Inka the most persecuted minority in
the world and a real puzzle for many
observers has been why on song Suchi
this Nobel Peace Prize winner has not
spoken out against these kinds of
atrocities and the reason I would argue
and I think if close observers of
Burmese politics very few thing that
would really substantially disagree with
this is that the because the Burmese
national identity is so closely defined
with with Buddhism it's very hard for
her to speak out against the forces of
Buddhism that the the Buddhist
organizations that that have been in
many ways calling for this as a way to
centralize their their their political
power and the regime so I hope what this
contrast has shown you is that in one
case we've had a highly inclusive sense
of the nation highly inclusive
nationalism but within one case used to
protect democracy whereas a highly
exclusive nationalism has been a force
for undermining it and the reason I want
really to to undertake this research
project is because Nash we live in a
world of nation-states and nationalism
is here to stay it's not going anywhere
anytime soon and that's because in the
words of Ernst turn on one of the
earliest scholars of nationalism the
cult of the ancestor
is a hugely legitimizing resource but if
nations are imagined communities I hope
that in some sense that's a hopeful
message because if they're imagined they
can be reimagined and I hope that some
of you who in the earlier as we began
the evening were not didn't were
unwilling to think of yourselves as
nationalists can be a part of the
conversation and making nationalism of
force for democracy so I was up there
[Applause]
[Applause]
let's bring these out and Margaret if
you want to come on the stage you are so
we'll have the conversation now just to
reminder to be thinking about your
questions because we want to hear your
questions as well and also just a shout
out to our members who are watching and
listening on the livestream you can also
hi you can also put in your questions
just use the chat box we'd love to get
some questions also from livestream take
it away
thank you and as I said I tend to waive
the mic around
so usually I'll try to keep it under
control if not hit you okay okay that
was great but it does raise a lot of
questions so I bet as a pointed if it
didn't yeah I can't help but think about
a variety of other contemporary
situations that are going on and
particularly the US and when I think
about the United States and nationalism
I have to say that I don't think of it
as necessarily being a resource for
democracy the US fits all your
definitions of something that was
founded on very exclusive principles
rather than inclusive principles and has
continued to be dealing with those that
sense of the ins and the outs the
marginalized
it's a racialized society it's a sexist
society is our most so how do you how do
you bring that together with your view
about nationalism as a resource for
democracy right right especially looking
at the current moment right no it's
actually the current moment that's an
many way cough you need to think about
some of these questions
just an old so so the way so the u.s. is
this really interesting case because in
some ways it has a very inclusive
founding Creed in the sense that what
some blazing on the Statue of Liberty
right some some of the the founding
Creed of the nation is not doesn't
centralize religion race the creat
now we also know 3/5 compromise that
blacks were not thought a thought of so
it's it's in in the kind of spectrum of
inclusive to exclusive I think as Roger
Smith has argued it's this guy's it's
kind of hybrid excuse me the kind of
hybrid national identity but it's
because you have at least an you have it
the possibly because you have a creedal
national identity added to some extent
at the founding of the United States
that you have I think some of the the
greatest forces for greater freedoms in
the United States have very much built
and harness the legitimating power of
those Creed's so I think you can draw a
straight line from kind of you know
these we hold these truths to be evident
that all men are created equal to
Abraham Lincoln's most famous kind of
words uttered at the Gettysburg Address
that you know we I we I am fighting this
war essentially to make that founding
American creed a reality to Martin
Luther King who stands of all the places
he can stand in front of the Lincoln
Memorial echoing the words of Lincoln
you know why I have a dream that my
children will see that that all men that
in this country all men and will at some
point be created equal now at some point
I hope we we keep going down that arc of
more inclusive more inclusive and you
know it's not now just men now it's
women right so I but I do think that
having the possibility of a creed that
allows that the the sense of who's the
end to expand in a way that if you have
a if you centralize a religious identity
in particular that has all these kinds
of consequences such as making those
institutions that get get to define who
is a good member of that religion also
get to define all of a sudden is a
member of a nation
so a very good I was I was there by the
way when Luther King made that speech
I'm that old but you know we were also
in a sea of people who didn't agree with
us and to say that the that that Creed
is really what dominates in a place like
the United States war in Britain or in a
number of other of the democratic
countries yeah is to really miss a lot
of the reality which you have competing
creeds right right I'm so I'm not making
an empirical statement that it does
dominate I'm saying that in when you
have credo nationalisms compared to non
cradle nationalisms that all things
being equal you're more likely to be
able to protect democracy under
circumstances in which the most
legitimating ideology around which is
nationalism I would argue allows for an
ever-growing group of people to be
included let me push you in a slightly
different direction because you're
emphasizing the creedal elements and
when I think of nationalism or
patriotism for that matter they usually
come up in times of war or revolution
mm-hmm so there's something else going
on that's also mobilizing right that the
Solidarity isn't just from the Creed
it's also from a creation of a common
enemy
sometimes that enemy is created
internally sometimes it's the
anti-colonial power sometimes it's a big
international war but I'm not hearing
war play any of those kinds of wars and
yet you told a story of an antique
colonial nationalism right what so I
think the reason that nationalism has
come up often in discussions of war is
because the war is a subset of a it's a
very severe kind of crisis but it is a
broad set of crises and you don't always
have to have crises through the form of
war you can have crises is through
crisis of succession in monarchies you
can have crises through a democratically
elected leader like the story I told
that begins then to overreach so I think
when you have these
people look around the cast around for
ideas which help to legitimate their
particular views I think that one thing
that you're also though really getting
at is that um you know Power has to be
organized before it can be used so one
thing that you know I didn't talk about
as much in the Burma Indian example but
that I do talk about my research
elsewhere is that you you have to have
an organized movement that espouses the
particular view of a nation for that to
be widely understood to become the
conception of the nation and then often
its educational curricula such as
textbooks that pass those conceptions of
the nation on but I also think of a lot
of these circumstances where where the
particular crisis which is often yeah
sometimes some of the other things you
were describing when it passes so does
the nationalism so does the resource so
what the mobilization was really about
was not around the greed but using that
Creed as a means to really mobilize
people to fight I think it's absolutely
right I think that's right yeah okay so
we agree yeah what may be I think you're
saying something different and I'm
trying to say that I'm not quite hearing
right so that when went paint claim that
nationalism is a resource for a
democracy or a key candidate or can be
also suggest that it has a kind of
persistence right oh right right okay so
the I centralized in might talk the kind
of founding moments right because I
looked at the set of countries which are
in which the nation is a relatively new
project right it's a it's a project
that's been really it's a 20th century
project and the founding moments often I
think cast a long shadow but that
doesn't mean that that can't be
reimagined I think you're right now
seeing in India a moment of reimagining
national identity in more exclusive ways
I think after Germany's you know after
the Second World War in Germany I think
you've seen a movement to try to
redefine the German national identity in
ways that go away from the classic blue
and bowden that was promoted under
Bismarck and the Romantic movement to a
much more kind of credo basis of
national so it's not that nationalisms
can't change over time but I agree that
there is a kind of lasting quality to
them and it absolutely gets invoked of
times of crisis because it's a resource
for legitimation but I'm also suggesting
that the nationalism has something to do
with where that state is placed in the
international system so your example of
Germany mm-hmm part of what created
post-world war ii german what you're
calling nationalism and might be named
something else has a lot to do with the
way in which europe was developing and
maintaining something that was
distinctive within that relationship so
it wasn't really about a resource that
was calling on a common like density
separate from the international sphere
your elements are all endogenous the
word we use it now yeah yeah well
internal to the kinds of factors that
made up the state in the first place
right as opposed to the international
world in which it lived right so I think
Europe is a pretty special case though
of this because most of the world is not
Europe where you know political
scientists or want us to quote as one
particular scholar Charles Tilly who
says war makes the state mistake makes
war right so in the European project the
state is a very strong state that's
selected through that's created by
centuries of war making and war fighting
which essentially has selects for US and
Canada different than that so I think
the US and Canada are also older States
but the states that I'm looking at
within which the vast majority of the
world's population lives now if the
national project and the state project
is a very new project it may happen
chronologically in quite close proximity
to each other so you know one of one of
ours
and for colleagues on ogres Malibu se is
now looking at the dynamics of state
state evolution or the emergence of the
state in Europe and really is arguing
that the the Chur the competition
between church and state is a central
dynamic and defying the European the
European state and nation project but
that is completely absent from nation
building in much of the developing world
because for the most part religions
aren't organized in the same land they
don't certainly don't have sovereignty
so I think - you know we look you know I
think when we look at the US and focus
on the US and Europe it's a it's I think
a very it's it's a relatively narrow
view of you know the here and the now -
we don't look at they'll think about the
long yeah absolutely the same way I
think yeah so so tans it's a one of the
other compared comparisons I'm looking
at is Kenya and Tanzania both countries
which come into being very very
relatively similar times both are very
multi-ethnic Kenya espouse is a very
ethnic based form of nationalism and
Tonja to Tanzania under near a doesn't
centralize ethnicity and today when you
look and they haven't had really
different histories in terms of
democracy but when you look at moments
of Elections scary it's much scarier in
Kenya and it's all around in ethnic
violence is what marks because ethnic
identities have been elevated in the
founding of the nation and so I think
that that is a resource other the other
pairs of countries I'm looking at our
single foreign relation I think some of
those dynamics play out as well so this
is not just a salad Asia story I've
deliberately chosen sets of countries
from different regions of the world that
look at how the ceramics play I just
didn't have time to talk about all of
them I think it's time for the audience
chance to say something yeah I have a
question early on you you had mentioned
you owns juxtaposed invention versus
imagination of nationality or
nationalism and it seems like that
doesn't necessarily take into account
that national nationalities actually
evolved and became so you couldn't have
it if it was just an invented you
wouldn't have national boundaries and so
since it's there it doesn't that kind of
degrade the fact that that you know
nations actually have beliefs that are
unique to that nation and different from
other ones and you know how does that
compare to nationalism versus democracy
so so the way that I think about us
often is to revert to kind of cases in
countries that I know so you know in 50
years before my German grandfather was
born Germany didn't exist as a nation
what it shared in common what was what
was it to be German you know there was
an a slow evolution of under Bismarck
that what it meant to be German was that
you spoke the German language but I
would contest that there was a certain
set of beliefs that Germany you know
held in common there wasn't even a
religion right because it was
essentially half half in terms of
Protestant Catholic so maybe there are
some countries which you can say have a
set of beliefs but I think those are
often instantiated in founding Creed's I
don't I I struggle to see in my research
that especially prior to the this the
forces of nationalism sweeping the globe
which really happens begins to happen in
the 18th century and and gains a lot of
steam in the 19th and 20th centuries
that these groups of peoples have a
national and have national identities
that are really that are based on
something other then you know this
invented idea that we that we share
something now in some cases
I think in Germany is the case of a
country where you had as a nation before
you had a state but in other cases like
France and England you had probably
States before you had nations so that
the way that that evolves is really
different over space and time it's
really hard to make one you know one
generalization about what that pattern
is hey so what I really want to take
from your research is an idea that this
pro-democracy nationalism inoculates
against the anti do not democracy
nationalism but when I think of the
riots in Gujarat which happened 20 years
after independence and five years before
that the time period you're talking
about and the rise of the BJP today I
can't take away that message so sort of
what is what is the message that I can
take away about the difference and the
interplay of these two types of
nationalisms yeah it's a great question
and let's better said than what I was
trying to write right but thank you so I
guess what I would say is that the word
inoculates is far too strong all the
explanations that political scientists
have for when democracy does or doesn't
come about they're all probabilistic
explanations they're not that's nothing
not a super diverse ethnic group a super
high level of economic development
nothing is an abs is absolutely
sufficient to become a democracy so the
claim that I'm making is that all else
being equal and of course nothing else
is pretty cool right because countries
are very particular and spaces and time
space and time specific creations but
that all else being equal a relatively
flat and open porous conception of what
it means to be a member of that nation
is a resource for democracy because at
subsequent moments of political crisis
when you have political entrepreneurs
pushing to get to power they if there is
by contrast a narrative of nation that
create that specifically sets aside a
group as not being core to defining the
nation that a moments of crisis that
particular group can be more easily
targeted by politicians in power and
that's what you see happening with
Muslims in right there were Hingis in
Myanmar it's what you see today
happening in India and what you saw when
Modi was the Chief Minister of Gujarat
which is when the riots that you
mentioned happened he was very much been
pushing a Hindu nationalist vision and
it's not a coincidence that's exactly
where you saw the riots happening in
India because it's where the chief
politician in power was pushing a
majoritarian view of what it meant to be
a citizen of that nation so to go back
to your question what do I take away
from this talk it's not that anything
inoculates democracy and democracy is
only as strong as our belief in it as
our willingness essentially make
sacrifices on behalf of a particular way
of organizing and sharing power but what
I can say is that in addition to all
those structural factors which to make
democracy a little bit more likely so if
you're a little bit wealthier a little
bit more likely if you don't have a oil
and gas as a major part of your export
democracy is a little more likely and
what I want to add to the conversation
is when you have a nationalism that's
relatively egalitarian and makes
democracy a little more likely for the
reasons I mentioned except that in all
these cases you have both nationalism
right so I think that's another yeah
yeah yeah so just briefly I think that
that was that was a question I was sure
I was gonna get so high you know when
you're talking about one nationalism or
there are lots of kinds of nationalists
and I think that's absolutely true
founding moments provide particularly
powerful narratives of what the nation
is but of course those narratives are
contested and changing over time but it
you know they're often surprisingly
durable
and what you see you happening in India
right now is a sustained attempt to
change what the national identity is and
to the extent that it endures its
empower it begins to change National
Curriculum
which you know is exactly what we're
seeing that will become a resource for
essentially promoting one form of
democratic breakdown which is when those
Civil and Political liberties are
systematically denied to the out groups
I want to just say I mean there are all
these structural elements that need to
be in place that are very fragile when
they fall apart but I'm wondering you
brought up this phrase common humanity
and then sort of went by it and I'm
thinking that that's actually the one of
the most important elements in thinking
about democracy per se because that's
not an idea which was common until the
18th century it's particularly a Western
idea which isn't holding up all that
well on the West and a more certainly
not in this country and I'm wondering if
the sense that there is a common
humanity actually is indigenous to the
cultures to the nations that you're
studying because it seems a particularly
Western idea which has been exported but
we may not find fertile soil in a place
like India or Myanmar
yeah but you know India has so Marty
asana has written this wonderful book
called an argumentative Indian in which
he talks he sort of roots democratic
practices far back in Indian history now
I think this is a little bit of smoke
and mirrors actually because look I
think most societies for most of human
history have been you know deeply
hierarchical organizations so I think
you're right that democracy is this
relatively new set of practices now you
know leaving aside the kind of ancient
Greeks which of course had some very
limited form of democracy but you do
have you know I think apart I think it
would be hard to say that it's hard to
root democracy in India because you know
India has been a democracy for really
the 70 plus years since independence and
I think of very well-established
so I think it it is the example that
shows us it is possible to have
democracy in very different kinds of
contexts but I think one of the things
that makes it this kind of very fragile
egalitarian power-sharing arrangement
possible is a sense that we are all in
some sense as citizens equal and that's
where my research is trying to enter the
conversation and we'll we'll have one
more question thank you this has been
wonderful guys one more question right
here
hi there was a great talk
thank you so I have two questions and
the second one may not have anything to
do with your research work at all so
forgive me for that one so the first is
if you've at all compared Pakistan and
Bangladesh as as - well now -
nation-states and very similar in their
foundation but took very different hats
very different paths so I wonder what
you have to say about that and then the
second question which may not be
relevant is yes India gained
independence and then formed a
nation-state which didn't exist as as it
exists today it didn't exist before but
it did have mobile room for centuries
mm-hmm much like the colonial rule and I
wonder if if you've thought about what
caused a set of movers the political
entrepreneurs as you call them to move
in the direction that they did at the
end of the British colonial era but not
before so what was what was so different
about those two colonial rules and I
call them tools so what was the what was
the nature of how they ruled perhaps you
know if you have anything to say about
that well it's almost like I planted
those questions those are very perfectly
answered by my I mean those are those
are the questions of my first book which
I ask why does India look so different
from Pakistan which then becomes
Pakistan and Bangladesh
and in a minute the the core argument of
that book is that the elites leading the
nationalist movements of these countries
are both completely self-interested and
they push a vision of the nation that
essentially they can in order to access
greater political power but that in one
case of the colonial elite they're very
much the sorry the colonial a the new
urban educated middle class that goes to
the colonial institutions of Education
they see their power being advanced by
pushing for more representative
institutions because they're not
representative in the colonial
institutions
whereas in Pakistan it's the landed
aristocracy for but a large part that is
very much tied up in the colonial regime
so they see their power as being
protected by pushing against democratic
institutions and in the process they
build very good different kinds of
political parties so that's the core
argument of the book and that very much
talks about I think it has a lot of
resonance in the kinds of regimes you
see both in Pakistan to a lesser extent
Bangladesh because that's a slightly
different story I think a sort of hybrid
of a more inclusive one than Pakistan in
a less include exclusive one than India
so and I think that's also relevant to
your second question which is how do I
think of the Mogul and the colonial
empires as as conditioning the emergence
of the nationalist movement so I think
it does so invert in very interesting
ways because the PAC's of nationalist
movement is led by elites who are
sitting and their erstwhile head of the
colonial at the Mughal Empire so they're
in a particular part of what is then
United Provinces and what is today with
the pradesh right so those so it's it's
that region that gives rise to this this
this movement for pakistan and it's they
it's their clothes their that the fact
that their interests are closely bound
up with the mogul regime and then with
the colonial regime that leads them to
resist calls for greater representative
institutions and by contrast that pushes
this new elite who would very much
benefit from it towards newly towards
more representative political
institutions
thank you my let's have a big round of
applause for both Margaret and Maya and
I want to mention it's popped up a
couple times but your first book is the
promise of power the origins of
democracy in India and autocracy in
Pakistan and that's still in print I'm
seeing it here on Amazon so it's it's
so-so look that up if you want to do it
as as always with our speakers in this
series uh Margaret and I are going to be
sticking around so we hope that you here
in the audience will stick around
continue the conversation I know there
are a bunch more questions in the
audience and we still have some work to
do to figure out nationalism completely
so let's do it before we leave the room
tonight right one last thing to thank
both Maya and Margaret for being on our
stage is a long now challenge coin which
we like to give to our speakers Margaret
is earning multiple at this point thank
you
again it's great to have you back and
yeah we really appreciate this is a
timely conversation and a peek at a work
that is still in progress so it's
exciting to see where this will go we'll
be keeping an eye on it let's give one
more big round of applause for
[Applause]
[Music]